okay let's now discuss the crowd at
donald trump's rally donald trump's
campaign
was hugely trolled on saturday night and
the the story really bears telling
because it is
so emblematic of how the trump
administration and trump campaign are
mismanaged and also of how easily
triggered and thin-skinned donald trump
and his followers are
so the venue where they held the rally
had a maximum capacity of 19
000. donald trump and his campaign
manager
and a whole bunch of other people were
insisting we've had hundreds of
thousands of ticket requests
we've had a million tickets requested we
are not going to be able to fill the
requests there's too much demand
so many people want to go this will be a
historically huge
rally and it couldn't possibly have gone
more
embarrassingly wrong in terms of
attendance so first of all
the signs that things weren't going so
well
uh were when they started uh putting
together this
overflow stage which donald trump
believed that they would need
and the overflow stage was for all the
people who would show up and not be able
to get in other words people in excess
of the 19
000 that could fit in the stadium so
they were going to do sort of like a
separate speech
for the overflow crowd maybe have mike
pence address them maybe have trump talk
to them
nobody was there they shut down the
entire
overflow area while the rally was still
going on
secret service clearing the area and
breaking down the american flags and
crowd control barriers just not even
necessary
but here's the genius part and we're
still trying to figure out the details
on this there have been a few different
uh ways this has been presented it
appears as though
when this event was announced and ticket
requests became available the form that
you fill out was was made available
people not just from all over the
country but all over the world
started requesting a ton of tickets to
make the trump campaign believe that
there was just
overwhelming demand to go to this corona
rally
and watch trump speak to a huge crowd
and this was the source of trump's
campaign manager brad parscale
claiming that a million people want to
go to this event
but in the end the fire department says
6 200 people went the capacity was 19
000 the entire upper level was almost
completely empty much of the floor
area was completely empty and by the way
imagine camping out all week when in
reality
you could have just walked up on the day
of and gotten right into this stupid
rally
now i i do want to be crystal clear
because i don't want
people to think i just wanted i don't
want to send mixed signals is the point
i don't even think this rally should
have been held from the per
from the perspective of coronavirus and
we should all be glad
that 6200 people instead of 19 000 or 62
000 were there
that will save lives there will be
people who don't get the virus
and some who don't die because donald
trump's
rally completely flopped versus if the
stadium had been full so
i'm glad from a public health standpoint
that this happened
i'm glad from a political standpoint as
well but the degree
of embarrassment for the trump campaign
is absolutely stun
stunning here is donald trump saying
we've never had an empty seat and we're
not going to have one in oklahoma this
was just a few days ago
done a great job oklahoma's had a very
low number
they've done really fantastic work they
have
a new a pretty new magnificent
arena as you probably have heard
we're getting exact numbers out but
we're either close to or over 1 million
people wanting to go
we have a 22 000 seat arena but i think
we're going to also take the
convention hall next door and that's
going to hold 40 000 so we'll have 22
000 plus 40 000
which would mean they would have over
900 000 people that won't be able to go
but
uh hopefully they'll be watching but
it's
uh it's an amazing nobody's ever heard
of numbers like this i think we're going
to have a
we're going to have a great time we're
going to talk about our nation how funny
is that
trump saying between the arena and the
overflow we're going to have
more than 60 000 people they had 6 200.
here's a bunch of people associated with
trump
claiming that a million people signed up
for the rally it's going to be huge
the first person is governor's tit from
oklahoma take a look and uh like you
said i don't know
people caught that but over a million
people have requested tickets to come to
come to this event look i think your
evidence though by
seeing one million ticket requests for
this rally in tulsa i think it's time
they're so excited about it
that you have no idea and we have had so
many sign ups you know there are lines
of people now and we won't be there for
three days they have lines of people
right now trying to get into the arena i
mean they'll be there they'll be early
how many people in one of those early
front rows
how many people signed up do you know
over a million people
uh requested tickets well there's just a
hunger for
the rallies and so you have this massive
crowd you have nearly a million tickets
that are demand are demanded out there
people pre-filling out their
applications and why not to come in
what are you gonna do with all these
people that literally could be hundreds
of thousands of people trying to come
and you've only got 19 000 seats indoors
what about all those other people what
are you going to do with them
well there is an overflow crowd but it
really is a testament to
people are ready to move on and
especially in oklahoma
hearing the the word ex-specially from a
governor is always a little jarring but
the really jarring thing
is that they were expecting hundreds of
thousands of people to show up in
support of donald trump
and 6200 showed up a
third of the arena's capacity and that
is
good we should all be glad because of
how
much better that is in terms of
coronavirus
they sort of tried to make it a little
less
embarrassing by claiming 12 000 people
were there but again
the fire department is good at
estimating crowd size
they said it was 6 200 people now there
are rumors that donald trump is furious
with his campaign manager brad parscale
we're going to talk more about that
later how could parscale let trump be
this embarrassed
here is trump when he landed from the
rally uh that night
looking extremely tired low energy
not happy and i mean listen would you be
happy if after all this buildup
room for 62 000 including the overflow
area
a million supposed ticket requests and
you go
and there are 6200 people and the entire
thing is mocked
endlessly i'd also be furious now one
other thing
some on the right tried claiming that
attendance was lower than expected
because of anti-trump protesters okay
the framing was hundreds of thousands of
people sixty 000 people a million people
did want to go
but because of these violent and
aggressive liberals that showed up
and intimidated trumpists trump has
stayed away number one
if you have a million people that want
to go and 6200 show up
you're saying that you know 99 point
whatever percent of trumpists
are dissuaded from going to support
their dear leader
by some silly liberal snowflakes who
don't even carry guns showing up
what the rugged conservatives are going
to say
sorry i'm not going to go see our lord
and savior in person
because of these little liberals that
showed up that's
actually the claim that you're making of
course it's complete and total bs
and what i'm going to show you next are
some clips of trump campaign staff
humiliated when trying to explain away
what happened here
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video